depuis une semaine les enquêteurs sont à
la recherche de gisements cuppitt cet
agent de sécurité de 49 ans employé à
anti protection une entreprise de
surveillance et de gardiennage
selon son collègue qui a serait lui
aussi le service le soir du samedi 29
février dernier il a quitté ce poste de
garde du port de fort de france ou bien
après 23h depuis dans cette petite
maison située à hauteur du monde seront
au lorrain l'attenté est longue très
longue mais mon corps hier j'ai appelé
j'ai fait son numéro
je tombe toujours sur la messagerie ça
fait mal mais la gendarmerie ne donne
pas d'information
rien du tout l'enquêté en cours
l'enquêté en cours et voile alors j'ai
laissé un jean marc pitte originaire de
sète mari passionné de sport et le fils
aîné d'une famille de trois enfants sa
mère est doublement affecté par la
disparition de son fils en quelles que
soient les conditions pour le retour
c'est lui seul que j'avais martinique
si j'avais besoin de quelque chose je
faisais appel à lui il venait tout de
suite cissé dieuze est très dur ou une
maman d'autant plus que je comme je vous
ai dit que j -pl d'humour ou pas nous
subitement est lui encore c'est bien
pire parce qu'on ne le retrouve pas
jusqu'à ce jour le vécu de jean marc
capitte n'a pas été localisé
toutes les tentatives de recherche de sa
famille se sont révélées vaines à 1
organisé des battues sur le lorrain sur
sainte-marie et le secteur gourmand
c'est joseph une voiture qui a fait la
trace donc on doit revenir sur ce
secteur-là il certainement pas ces pans
de chou en fonction de ceux qui seront
prises
tous gardent espoir par instinct la mère
du disparu pensant qu'il aurait été
séquestré elle lance un appel aux
éventuels ravisseurs je suis la maman de
jean marc
je lance un appel aux gens qui
éventuellement pourrait le retenir
parce qu'il est soumis dit qu'il est
sous traitement et à ce moment il ya une
semaine qu'il n'a qu'il n'a rien pris
alors je vous en prie libéré le s'il
vous plaît si vous le retenez libérez le
pour l'heure les investigations de la
gendarmerie se poursuivre